let's let's let's let's throw a little
bit of rome in there was there like a
war conflict with rome during their
collapse
there was right barbarians julius caesar
and you might know even more about this
john
was uh leading his troops up north and
he basically
conquered all of gaul he was returning
as like the hero of gol and they were
going to try and get him on political
charges and put him in the way
that's right so so what happened so what
started happening in the roman republic
is that is that um so when you were
in rome as a leader uh you were you were
immune uh
to kind of law fair uh you were not
allowed to you know do this thing where
you just bring like lawsuits and
lawsuits and lawsuits everything
um um but if you but once you're out of
uh
power you know then then they could do
that to you and they started to do that
um and uh you know julius caesar being
seen
as the threat uh that he was um
and you know being outside of roman
territory and at that point being a
military leader not
um uh a tribune or anything like that
he was like he you know he had the
classic choice to make as to whether to
cross the rubicon with his army
um and and and he made that choice
because you know he was he was facing
you know he was facing political and
probably physical extermination or he
was going to win he's going gonna win or
he's gonna lose that was the thing about
uh threatening to impeach and use
political things to go after your
political opponents that eventually one
of them is gonna snap
and that's what caesar did he crossed
the rubicon which was basically the the
was it a wall or something that's a
river really i think it's more of a
stream than a river but it's very famous
it's like um it protects it it borders
rome and it's symbolically you are not
allowed to bring military troops beyond
that route
that's correct that violates roman so
but he did it he was like you know what
it's either either i don't and they
arrest me and they destroy me or i
take control of the city that's right
and look that's it'll get assert at a
certain
at a certain point when uh you know
tyranny becomes extreme enough
um it creates the the the conditions
you know for certain things to happen
what if we're in the calm before the
storm
a lot of people thought that 2020 was
the time at which
trump was facing all these charges so
would he cross the rubicon
the left is trying to claim that he did
with january 6 but he clearly did not
but what if 2024 is when you know
because maybe trump said look
we're going to run again we'll run 2024
and we'll win we're going to win back
the house
we're going to run again we'll win but
what if what happens if something
happens and
trump done win we have i think social
media you can't
take the capital that doesn't exist
anymore our government is decentralized
now so there's no
place to march troops into would have to
be like some organized digital
cyber uh you know you'd have to shut
down
all communications take over yeah
certainly 2024 is i mean you know we
used to say that 2016 was going to be
one of the most important elections ever
in 2020 was going to be one of the most
important elections ever
2024 is going to be extremely
uh extremely uh high stakes um
i i i happen to believe that and i i i
like
donald trump i'm i'm a big big trump fan
i hope
that he runs again i think he has
unfinished business and i think he can
turn the country around
i personally believe he is going to win
by such a
a massive margin in 2024 that you know
we're not going to have um
issues and i pray that i i i agree i
agree at least for now we'll see you
it's very very
early on it is we're in one of the worst
years for political uh
shows so this is for everybody you can
understand um i tell people like
the year after the presidential election
it's just like your lowest traffic
lowest ad rate it's brutal then you get
the midterm which everything improves
and you get the
the campaign the primary year for the
presidential in 2023
so then it's like everything picks back
up and boy our election year is great
for political content but we're in that
when that law so we have so much
i think you're gonna have i think you're
going to have a really good 20 24 i
don't think
what for your show first no i'm not i'm
i'm not entirely convinced i think
people need to understand that 2016 was
insane
how insane it was i was in san jose and
i watched this
mob outside the trump rally chased down
some six-year-old kid
attacking him i saw a guy who got
punched in the mouth
because someone said he was a trump
supporter but he was actually a bernie
supporter
i watched them shove an elderly couple
in their late 60s to the ground
grabbed their maga hats and set them on
fire cheering i watched a guy walking
out going yay trump and a guy runs up
with a bag and
whacks him in there with it i film this
video gets a million views in a day
that was i think 2015 that's how insane
things were
then we get 2020. look at what happened
with january 6 at the very least a ride
at the capitol
insane and i keep telling people i see
no reason for this to de-escalate
now you're getting the brunt of the of
the of the federal government going
after trump supporters do you think
people are sitting there just being like
well it sucks but i'm going to calm down
or do you think they're being like
stop and leave me alone now i'll tell
you my the funniest
smear against me the splc posted this
tweet of mine
where i said something like i think
we've passed the point of no return
the bridge has been the nation has been
so divided we can never go back and
civil war seems inevitable
and i was quoting a story i was actually
quote tweeting somebody
and the story said that like far-right
groups wear t-shirts calling for a
second civil war
so basically i'm like the news reported
these far-right groups are driving
around demanding civil war and i'm like
feels like a civil war is gonna happen
and they criticize me for it
as if it was my idea listen it's gotten
so insane in this country
and right now we're in this lowly year
so it feels like
everything's maybe chilled a little bit
but look what they're doing with the 1-6
commission look what they're doing with
setting up capital police offices
when we get in the midterms and the
republicans are looking like they're
going to win
the democrats are going to start ripping
their hair out and banging their faces
on the wall
screaming on top of their lungs 2023
when trump gets back up on stage and
says ladies and gentlemen
i am running for president one more time
and everyone goes
and screams cheering and they're
throwing drinks in the air whatever
the democrats will start pulling their
hair out again
it is going to be worse than we saw in
2016. it is going to be worse than we
saw in 2020.
i'm not entirely i'm saying these things
to be pessimistic i'm saying there's
going to be a conflict
understand why maybe it will be like the
scale of conflict we don't know
but come on i i love this i i've talked
about the potential for civil war
there's been a bunch of studies
some national security experts there was
a story i think in the atlantic said
that they estimated between 35
and like 95 chance of a civil war in the
united states and i thought that was
insane
it's like 1 to 99 chance no no it's
because
because there was uh like 16 people
interviewed there was a wide range of
what they thought
but the average was something like 65 to
70 percent
so then i have people say to me they're
like so tim
remember last year when you were saying
that that we were headed towards a civil
war yeah what happened with that
and i'm like a bunch of people ride it
at the capitol and they go
oh i'm like did you think that things
calmed down since then
so a few years ago and i was like man if
this stuff keeps happening it's gonna
get worse
now we've got the one sick stuff going
on they're going after all these people
do you think that when they go after
that little old granny where they the
cop holds the door open for her
and threatens her or how about when the
feds went to that alaska woman's house
and kicked her door or whatever wrong
person do you think regular people are
sitting back like
this is fine or do you think people are
being antagonized to the point where
their brains are going to explode you
made me think of that meme with a dog
sitting in the house on fire going
this is fine yeah i i i totally agree
uh that the level of intensity is being
ratcheted up uh
you know to you know to a very dangerous
extent and i agree that it will continue
uh to do so in in the current course
that we're on
um until uh 2024. so so i know i i
totally agree with you that we're going
to see uh you know
we're gonna we're gonna see we're gonna
see the same kind of and probably more
conflict during the election uh than we
did in 2016 and 2020.
i i just believe and i hope and i pray
that
you know trump wins by such a margin um
that you know it kind of
puts everything uh you know a 49 state
landslide
hey i i really i really think it could
be i really think it could be big i
i think that you know like you said like
i think you just said i mean regular
i think the left terribly underestimates
regular americans and i think when they
think that they have an advantage they
press it and they overreach
uh very much but i've heard a lot
there's been a lot of historical
comparison so
obviously we're talking about rome and
crossing the rubicon but i mean are
there really that many similarities or
is it just like a few things that people
like to to reference
right you you talked about you know you
talk about
oh oh oh no look i i mean i think it's
uh
i forget who it is i mean one of my my
second or third favorite podcaster after
you uh dan carlin has a podcast name
uh hardcore history um and it's really
you know amazing um and
and uh any you know big series on raw
big series on
genghis khan that he calls him that i
love and alexander the great i'm a huge
um fan of
but he's fond of saying that you know
history doesn't necessarily repeat but
it rhymes
um and it rhymes because human nature
you know is eternal
um and you know there are trends and
forces that change uh
you know there are individuals that that
that
rise to to uh significance who have
such a force of nature that they can you
know alter things
so you know um you can't say hey
we're exactly in a situation that the
roman republic is in we're heading the
exact
same direction and outcome um but but
there are there are definite
definite uh similarities uh for sure
that we that we should that we should
draw lessons from you know and and try
and try to avoid you know certainly
a lot of people have likened it to
weimar germany yeah some people have
like
but some people have likened it to um
the spanish civil war
i i look i think i think the 1930s uh
comparison to you know uh to the to the
threat of the third reich
is very apt in the following sense which
is um you know and people are talking
about
this some of them uh but i don't think
enough are but i think that i think that
the chinese communist party is is an
existentially uh dangerous threat to us
and to freedom in the world right now i
don't think we're paying
enough attention to it i don't think
we've been serious enough about it i
think we need to completely decouple
from china and we need to to isolate to
isolate them
uh and be in be building a sort of an
alliance of liberty uh that
steve bannon one of my other favorite
podcasters likes to say with you know
nations like japan and um
india and australia and we need to be um
preparing for things
with respect one of the things about the
german uh how it reminds me of weimar
germany is the burning of the reichstag
which happened right after hitler got
into power i think was 1933.
uh the the building the capital
parliament building burned down
and he blamed the communists that was a
false flag apparently
no one's been able to prove and they've
done the math and they're like there's
no way
one guy could light the whole building
on fire american conspiracy theory
so theories have arrived that he burned
his own reichstag down and then used
that as
a reason to lock down the entire country
and start stripping them of their civil
rights
what was the the the special security
bill that was passed because of that the
the um appeasement act is that what it's
no no the uh the the
an act that was passed in germany yeah i
i the the on the tip of my tongue
you got it yeah yeah yeah it's on the
tip of my tongue i don't know the answer
abling act
yep enabling the enabling act that's
what it was oh it's so close
enabling act oh the enabling act what is
that was his excuse he's like we need
more power we need to start arresting
people
and uh we're watching similar things and
it's now like you said it doesn't
it doesn't repeat it rhymes a lot of
people come out and they're like oh nazi
germany i'm like look it's going to be
different but it's going to be similar
in a lot of ways
what are we saying we have an
ideological faction
demands purity they are racial
identitarians they want law based on
race
and they are indoctrinating children a
lot of similarities there and then
1-6 you've got i don't even like saying
one six makes it sound like 911 but like
this
this thing i don't know that it was a
false flag i've heard that there were
police officers involved with letting
people into the building that's a fact
that's a fact that is a is a fact
i have one i have one client named alan
hostetter uh you know uh
former police chief from orange county
and uh he might be someone you want to
have on the show someday
to talk all about this because he's
happy to talk all about it but you know
he he is an individual
um you know who seems to have had uh
federal agents uh around him for a long
time um leading up
to january 6th um and so you know
there's they're just
they're serious questions there's
numerous videos where the police
opened the door to allow people and in
one video a cop didn't say they were
they were they were urging people
sometimes they were letting people in
sometimes they were urging cops are
taking selfies with people
they're like hey in one video cobb says
don't agree with it but i agree with
your right to protest
as people walk past them waving so it
could have been just mass
disorganization
or it could have been intentionally like
hey we can use this
as an excuse to impose i think i think
you all are missing the bigger picture
the police were in on it each and every
one of those capitol police officers
were like
we're gonna let all of our trump maga
friends in the building
so each and every one of these cops why
aren't they being investigated why
aren't they being injured
so i so i will tell you um we're gonna
put a lot of uh capital police officers
on the witness stand when we try these
cases um why did you open the door for
these people
that's a pretty good cross-examination
question too yeah
it really is the jury hear that question
what's it going to say here's a video of
you opening the door and letting him in
i want to do it
that's what i would have said i wanted
to avert a riot so i let them in
so they didn't smash me up okay is it
trespassing
not if i let him in haven't you seen the
episode of simpsons where
i think it's wiggum or someone tells
homer that if someone enters your
property you can kill him and he goes
hey flanders i think it doesn't work if
you invite him in
he's like oh right what if whatever that
does create a an analytical legal
problem what if you are the process what
if you invite them in under duress
what does that mean meaning that you
fear for your life so you let them pass
like someone you're like you're like
three levels into the movie inception
on that one yeah yeah i'm like hey come
over here and go in i'm like uh these
people are gonna break me up
if someone is in the front of your
building and they have like weapons
and they're threatening you and so
you're scared and you open your door
that i understand
in these videos quite literally it's a
bunch of old people doting about
waving little american flags and the
police just open the door up
stand aside and say don't agree with it
but agree with your right to protest as
people walk in
there's another video where the cop
literally just opens the door and one
cop poses for a selfie with people
like dude you're not gonna tell me
that's duress now i think those cops got
in trouble right the selfie cops
i i don't i don't know the answer to
that question yeah i do know there's
another video that just came out
that that that appear appears to show uh
folks sort of frantically changing into
um
you know different attire sort of other
trees um yeah i've seen that i've seen
that there's a video where one of the
first breaches in the building they were
all
in black clad you know blackout gear to
obscure who they were and their
identities
and that's not a typical thing of uh of
trump supporters it certainly is not uh
but
but there were a bunch of a bunch of
trump supporters who said they were
going to dress like antifa
so the key the key thing is and again um
you know i have to discipline myself to
be careful about talking about the
merits of these cases but i mean
the important thing is uh where's
where's the video
where where's the 14 where's the 14 000
or 15 000 hours of video now to
be fair um you know the the department
of justice and the prosecutors
you know say and i i i believe that they
are in the process of setting up sort of
a massive uh sort of database in the
cloud that will have all that
video that will allow defense counsel um
you know to to
to search through it um that uh is still
going to take a long time to get
set up and it's going to take a massive
amount of time to review um
all of that because we need to review
all of it to understand
um you know what what happened that that
day
um i also believe we should be seeing
some video from before
and after um that day i mean you know
what why is it just relevant
um you know what what which what the
video shows for
january 6th um january 5th and january
7th i think it's important to point out
there were violent people lots of them
there's a lot of video there that's
that's ridiculous there are people from
the barricades out
storming up and and ramming police we
had uh richie mcginnis i think
this guy's everywhere was actually
squeezed in between
rioters shoving against these cops and
one cops like
screaming as he's being crushed so all
that stuff definitely happened
now the problem is the democrats on the
left
show that and they say look look look
look
and i think it is part partially a
problem that many on the right are just
like
showing the cops opening doors let's
talk about all of it they were bad there
were people there engaged in very bad
activities right
but there are a lot of people who are
being charged when they were essentially
welcomed into the building
confused and understanding what was
going on uh that that is just
that is just accurate what you just said
um and and you know very interestingly
uh
and i'm i'm not a fan of fbi director
christopher wright i mean when
christopher wray was asked uh you know
questions by forget which republican
congressman it was
and asked um hey um constituents in my
district are wondering about these
people who were you know
ushered into the building and uh that
they're being um
charged you know how many people are
there like that and you know in classic
christopher ray fashion you know he
dodged and ducked and
varicated and simply would not just
simply would not go there and
not even remotely answer the question
because it's political
it's for power never let a good crisis
go to waste
that that is one of the tried and true
uh tactics of all time with respect to
taking over
no i don't i don't think the riot is on
par with like the burning of you know
the reichstag or whatever nothing really
got destroyed did it
they burned down the building didn't
they no no in uh on january 6. there
were some there were some actual
historical
uh artifacts that took some damage when
they when windows got broken and
there was like an old bookshelf or
something they burned the entire wreck
shack i don't think anyone died
yeah so so it does it does it doesn't
really matter though because
there was something symbolically
destroyed uh it was the the normal
process by which they certified the
electoral votes
so that process is shocking to people it
wasn't a physical destruction it was
more of a
metaphysical you know oh there's
attracted the process yeah
yeah and so it feels like an attack on
the on the on the uh structures of the
countries
you know abstract there there's are
there's
actually an interesting legal issue on
that front which we've found
you know some emotions on um in our
cases which is that it is actually
unclear um under the existing case law
as to whether or not uh you know that
process that day
the the certification of the electoral
votes actually qualifies as
legally and technically an official
proceeding as that is interpreted under
the case law
because because those have to have a
sort of a quasi-judicial
um function to them that that it can be
argued um
did not exist that day now that that is
unsettled i mean the courts will decide
um yeah decide that
um but look i but i but i really believe
and i've said
many times i think the institutions that
really fell down
in all of this so to speak are the state
legislatures especially including uh gop
controlled state legislatures because
there's
there's
a the constitution's designed to avoid
something like this and it's
it's very clear um if there are
questions about
if there are any questions the um the
state legislatures
you know can and should uh not on
january 6. we're talking about
back in like you know december when the
electoral college mates in the states
they are allowed to very clearly under
the constitution
uh simply not uh send elector or slate
of electors
uh because they feel there are questions
if that occurs and
if either candidate if no candidate gets
270 electoral votes
it goes to the house under the 12th
amendment where each state delegation
gets one vote
and there is a process thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time